[Music]
this morning we're remembering a
one-of-a-kind voice in American music
Little Richard a pioneering performer
who helped rhythm and blues become rock
and roll
he died Saturday after battling bone
cancer Little Richard was 87 with the
unforgettable opening lyric to his smash
hit tutti frutti
Little Richard crashed the pop charts
like a force of nature in 1956 no one
had ever heard anything like him
including a young man who'd later find
fame with Creedence Clearwater Revival
John Fogerty got to perform with Little
Richard at the Grammys in 2008 I felt
that his voice had the ultimate rock and
roll tone you know that grip that edge
that he sang with born Richard Penniman
in Macon Georgia as Little Richard he
developed a high energy stage act he was
just over the top
wild flamboyant the Black Keys Dan
Auerbach if you ever liked the
flamboyant said rock and roll band you
know you owe all that to Little Richard
producer Quincy Jones hailed Richard as
an innovator whose influence is seen in
genres from gospel to hip hop raised in
a religious household Richard was 19
when his bootleggers father was killed
leaving him to reconcile his love of God
and his attraction to men he spoke to 60
minutes at Bradley in 1985 but there was
must have been a terrible stigma
attached to that in Macon Georgia in
those days oh I was called everything
but a Reuben sandwich when he first
started touring in the mid 1950s he told
Rolling Stone magazine he faced such
severe racism he was forced to sleep eat
and dress in his car but ultimately he
said his shows started bringing black
and white audiences together
South Alabama North Carolina Kentucky a
Mississippi Arkansas they start just
falling in line you know little Richard
would call himself the innovator the
originator and the architect of rock and
roll it was no exaggeration I would say
you know you boys and girls out there if
you ever dare to try and do rock and
roll you better go look up Little
Richard and see how it's done